[Musique]
et plus deux jours avant le vote le
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle ici en france je serai ce
dernier oui bonsoir raphaël bonsoir à
tous et l'électorat semble toujours très
volatil selon les experts de la
fondation jean jaurès sur les deux
derniers mois plus de la moitié des
français ont visiblement changé au moins
une fois d'avis soit en passant d'un
candidat à un autre soit en décidant
d'aller voter puis de s'abstenir alors
pour les candidats quels qu'ils soient
c'est évidemment le moment ou jamais de
convaincre le récap politique est signée
florent rodo et lucie la tour
c'est l'histoire des petits candidats
qui ont désormais autant la parole que
les autres ce pied d'égalité
nathalie arthaud de lutte ouvrière ne va
pas s'en plaindre ne venez surtout pas
en revanche lui parler de la future
remise de 18 centimes par litre
d'essence décidé par l'exécutif
dérisoire selon elle les salariés les
travailleurs tous ceux qui sont à la
retraite mais qui ont bossé toute leur
vie ils ne demandent pas la charité ils
veulent pas l'aumône ils veulent pouvoir
vivre dignement de leur salaire retraite
à 65 ans rsa conditionné c'est le plan
d' emmanuel macron pour une saison 2 à
l'elysée une dérive à droite selon la
socialiste anne hidalgo
culpabiliser ces gens-là et traiter ceux
qui les aident de lâche c'est ça le
projet d' emmanuel macron c'est ça cette
fameuse france qui marcherait sur deux
jambes la jambe gauche et la jambe
droite là il saute à cloche-pied met
alors à cloche-pied avec son pied droit
une élection présidentielle qui seraient
manipulés par des journalistes aux
ordres de l'elysée celle intime
conviction de nicolas dupont aignan télé
de a à z par des médias complaisants de
monsieur macro est une oligarchie que
vous représentez je vous dis qu'être
utilisent ce que vous faites je dis ce
que je veux pas mise mais ce que vous
représentez une casse eric zemmour lui a
encore choisi de parler sécurité visite
à sevran théâtre de violences urbaines
où un homme a été tué en tentant
d'échapper aux policiers brûler des
camions des voitures et sert à
rien est admissible comme il fallait et
terroriser les terroristes il faut
éradiquer la racaille
allez on termine avec ces images en
corse de jean lassalle favorables comme
le président et d'autres à l'autonomie
de l'île de beauté petit moment de
détente musicale
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
et parmi les candidats l'une est de
retour en campagne sur le terrain après
avoir été immobilisé par le cos vide oui
c'est valérie pécresse un soulagement
pour la candidate et l'air dont la
campagne déjà poussive avaient été
rendues encore plus difficiles à mener
en distance yale négative dont coco vie
19 depuis hier soir elle s'est rendue
dès ce matin dans les eaux de france à
la rencontre de chefs d'entreprise à
marcq en baroeul puis à roubaix récit de
cette journée par notre reporter car
inachevé
pour cette reprise de campagne après
quatre jours passés à l'isolément la
candidate les républicains s'est
affichée en femme de terrain d'abord
devant des chefs d'entreprise où elle a
défendu son bilan à la tête de la région
ile-de-france et défendu son programme
économique en faveur du pouvoir d'achat
moins d'impôts moins de bureaucratie
elle a assumé ses erreurs ses échecs ses
difficultés ses maladresses dans les
médias établissant un parallèle avec un
entrepreneur qui selon elle peut avoir
des difficultés financières mais avoir
le droit à rebondir et puis elle s'est
offert une longue déambulation dans un
quartier populaire de roubaix miné par
la pauvreté par le trafic de drogue et
non certains commerces sont accusés
d'islamisme radical écouter et bien
cette librairie qui vient de fermer à
l'instant parce que nous arrivions et
bien
si je suis président de la république
donnerait le pouvoir au maire et au
préfet de fermer administrativement les
librairies qui vendent des livres qui
prêche des idéologies radicales et
contraires à la république travail
sécurité laïcité à défaut d'une campagne
flamboyante valérie pécresse mise sur
ses thèmes chers à la droite pour tenter
de rattraper son retard dans les
sondages
la autres candidats à la peine dans les
sondages c'est yannick jadot qui ne
ménage pas ses efforts à l'écologiste
oui incisif dans les interviews il
multiplie aussi les déplacements il
était aujourd'hui sur la plage du lion
près de saint brieuc en bretagne pour
dénoncer la prolifération des algues
vertes et pour tenter d'imposer enfin
l'urgence climatique au coeur de cette
campagne et pourtant il ne parvient pas
et on ne peut que constater l'absence de
dynamique autour de sa personne alors
comment l'expliquer reportage de maya
anaïs hayettes again et deux maréchaux
stream
l'elysée vaut bien une danse
si yannick jadot mouiller la chemise
malgré les sondages c'est parce qu'il
espère encore être l'homme providentiel
katende les écologistes là vraiment le
charisme et les épaules à bord diriger
le pays et j'en suis persuadé hélas ce
talent là rassembler toutes les
tendances à 54 ans cet ancien de
greenpeace s'inscrit dans une longue
lignée de candidats verts
[Applaudissements]
rené dumont le premier écologiste à se
présenter en 1974 le premier à perdre
aussi l'histoire retiendra son verre
d'eau plus que c'est un pour cent et
quelques dans les urnes là nous allons
bientôt manquer de l'eau et c'est
pourquoi je bois devant vous en 2002 les
écologistes passent pour la première et
dernière fois la barre des 5% un exploit
de noël mamère qui aujourd'hui montent
au créneau si on lui parle résultats
surtout en comparaison avec ses voisins
allemands ou autrichiens les allemands
ils ont la chance d'avoir la
proportionnelle que nous réclamons
depuis longtemps et les écologistes à ce
titre et par cette étude juridique
institutionnel peuvent contribuer à la
vie des institutions alors cette
présidentielle marqueur athènes la fin
de la malédiction verte les militants
n'en sont pas convaincus l'élection qui
tourne autour d'une seule personne
la nature ou confondre des écologistes
on n'est plus dans le collectif il ya
une culture et que le gist effectivement
on ait du mal à la faire passer
mais c'est vrai qu'en face ils nous ont
toujours traité punitif alors que
l'écologie finalement ses protecteurs il
ya cinq ans yannick jadot s'était
désisté en faveur de son allié
historique le parti socialiste cette
fois ci en pleine urgence climatique
confirmée par les rapports du giec le
géant vert fait cavalier seul fort de
ses récents succès aux européennes son
mouvement est la troisième force
politique française aux municipales les
écologistes prennent grenoble lyon
strasbourg il administre désormais plus
de deux millions d'habitants mais peine
toujours à faire passer leur message
nous portons à notre projet de société
qui n'est pas une société productiviste
qui était une société de sobriété nos
concitoyens n'aime pas penser un avenir
plus sobre avec près de 4000 spectateurs
à paris yannick jadot détient néanmoins
le record du plus grand meeting
écologistes français une petite victoire
qui lui a redonné de l'optimisme en
sortant de scène ce pic a rappelé un
proverbe de chez lui c'est à la fin de
la foire qu'on compte les bouses
et seller comme chaque mardi de notre
chronique la présidentielle pour les
nuls oui où l'on décrypte les
spécificités de l'élection
présidentielle en france qui peuvent
paraître complexes ou même étrange de
l'étranger aujourd'hui on s'intéresse au
financement des campagnes
présidentielles et on en parle ce soir
avec florence vinit nozal et florence
seule la réglementation sur le sujet est
très strict pour ce qui est d'abord du
montant des sommes dépensées tout à fait
parce que la course à l'élysée coûte
très très cher il faut traverser la
france à la rencontre des électeurs
organiser des meetings embauché une
équipe de campagne ça s'additionne très
vite alors on est très très loin des
centaines de millions voire milliards
dépensés par exemple pour l'élection
présidentielle aux états unis car en
france des plafonds sont prévus pour les
dépenses totales des campagnes on va
regarder un peu ça de plus près pour les
candidats présents au premier tour le
plafond des dépenses s'élève à à peu
près 16 8 millions d'euros vous voyez
c'est très très très précis et pour les
deux candidats présents au second tour
ses 22 et me millions d'euros alors
pourquoi est ce que les dépenses sont
limités en france et bien c'est tout
simplement au nom de l'égalité pour
éviter que les petits candidats soient
complètement écrasée par la force de
frappe financière des grands candidats
alors les dépenses ont augmenté les
ressources aussi puisque c'est l'état
qui rembourse une partie des sommes
engagées par les candidats dans la en
panne tout à fait c'est un remboursement
forfaitaire non négligeable qui dépend
du résultat d'un candidat le résultat
que le candidat obtient à l'élection et
le numéro fétiche vous le voyez là c'est
5 5% en dessous de la barre des 5%
l'état ne verse qu'à peu près 800 mille
euros mille huit cent mille euros vous
voyez là est au-dessus de 5% le
remboursement atteint 8 millions d'euros
dont 5,6 sacrée différence qu'on peut
voir par rapport à ces 5 % obtenir moins
de 5% c'est non seulement un échec
électoral ça peut coûter très très cher
alors un candidat peut aussi chercher un
financement privé pour sa campagne mais
là encore c'est très réglementé en
france par exemple les dons des
particuliers sont limités à 4600 euros
alors dernièrement les candidats peuvent
compter sur une aide précieuse qui ne se
mesurent pas financièrement et ça c'est
de l'aide des bénévoles c'est surtout le
cas pour les petits candidats on va
écouter nicolas dupont aignan lors de sa
première campagne présidentielle c'est
peut-être en 2012 et coûter le sang
bénévoles on pourrait pas fonctionner
parce que on n'a pas les moyens
financiers des autres donc vous savez
quand on a moins d'argent on est souvent
beaucoup plus malin et quand on n'a pas
d'argent on a des idées et une fois
l'élection terminée les dépenses donc
frais d'hôtel transport meeting tout
cela est méticuleusement épluchés par
une commission spéciale voilà c'est la
fameuse cncc fpc la commission nationale
des comptes de campagne et des
financements politiques
donc une équipe d'enquêteurs est chargé
de valider ou non les comptes des
candidats et à chaque élection il ya des
petites perles insolite de dépenses
refusé par la commission par exemple à
la dernière élection présidentielle
marine le pen s'est vu retoquer 111
euros d'achat d'anti moustiques lors
d'un voyage en guyane alors la
commission a jugé cette dépense éloigné
de la recherche de l'obtention de
suffrages des électeurs c'est ça le
critère de remboursement alors la
candidate d'extrême droite elle a estimé
que pour des raisons d'image il fallait
éviter d'être complètement couverte de
piqûres de moustiques pour autant ce qui
la défend ce qui se défend j'avoue mais
la défense a été retoqué quand même et
emmanuel macron lui s'est vu refuser le
remboursement des honoraires d'un
coaching vocal alors cette fois ci la
commission a jugé que ces frais
constitué des dépenses à caractère
personnel et du coup ne méritait pas
d'être remboursés par l'argent des
contribuables
merci beaucoup florence pour ce
décryptage donc sur le financement des
campagnes présidentielles rendez vous
donc mardi prochain pour un prochain
décryptage nom vient achever ma votre
archive du jour oui depuis hier raphaël
dont coup d'envoi officiel de la
campagne vous avez peut-être pu
apprécier les clips de campagne des
candidats à la présidentielle sur les
chaînes de télévision notamment ici sur
france 24 et c'était l'occasion pour
nous de nous replonger dans les clips du
passé et on n'a pas été déçu je vous
laisse découvrir le clip du candidat du
nouveau parti anticapitaliste philippe
poutou en mode parodie de jeu télévisé
questions pour un champion c'était en
2012 suivi du clip officiel du candidat
du mouvement écologiste indépendant je
sais pas si vous en rappelez raphaël
antoine waechter en
1997 regarder
[Musique]
alors vous devez trouver un candidat aux
élections présidentielles de 2012 un
indice en bas de votre écran pour vous
chez vous chers téléspectateurs
top je suis le candidat qui défend un
bouclier social candidat anti
capitaliste je prends la sortie urgente
du nucléaire et la création d'un grand
service public de l'énergie je suis je
suis je suis je
naturellement on se serre la main
pourquoi un castor dans cette campagne
le question identifie les écologistes
indépendants dans cette courte campagne
de plus cette espèce menacée est un
symbole alors antoine on se tait toi je
te tutoie toujours les amis
très pince-sans-rire entre stans était
sa marque de fabrique merci h rennes
verdien france 2022 l'heure du choix on
vous retrouve demain à la même heure et
nous on se retrouve dans 5 minutes pour
un nouveau journal rester avec